estamos entrando probablemente en la
década más apasionante y decisiva de la
historia de la humanidad
somos la primera generación plenamente
consciente de la crisis climática y
probablemente la última que seamos
capaces de cambiar el rumbo
por tanto es nuestra responsabilidad
hacernos preguntas acerca del sistema
que nos ha traído hasta aquí
mi objetivo hoy es que nos hagamos
preguntas grandes
que nos atrevamos a cuestionar el orden
económico mundial como causante de la
crisis climática
y que además aportemos soluciones
utilizando únicamente el sentido común
para ello os invito a que hagamos un
pequeño viaje
ese viaje arranca en los años 30 en eeuu
la gran depresión la gente perdía sus
trabajos
algunos saltaban por las ventanas de
desesperación las empresas cobraban todo
era un caos
el entonces presidente roosevelt en
carbón joven economista que me diera
todo lo perdido en la crisis
aquel joven economista aquí lo ven un
poco más mayor en la foto que reunió a
su equipo de trabajo y empezó a
recopilar información
jamás se imaginaría que el indicador que
presentó en el año 34 estuviese llamado
a ser la base del pensamiento económico
moderno
el propio kuznets advirtió de las
limitaciones de su indicador pero la
popularidad fue subiendo y subiendo
hablamos como ya imaginarán algunos del
producto interior bruto
saltamos a los años 60 aún con las
reticencias del creador de la criatura
el baby y lo más importante su
crecimiento pasó a ser el objetivo de
todas las economías del planeta
desde mediados del siglo pasado nos
convertimos en adictos al crecimiento
del pib
el pib mide los bienes y servicios
producidos en una economía en un periodo
de tiempo normalmente un año
esto lo hace midiendo el consumo
midiendo la inversión el gasto público y
las exportaciones netas
pero el pib no distingue entre cosas
buenas y malas si yo me tomo una cerveza
sube el pib
si el gobierno invierte en educación
estos son cosas buenas especialmente en
la primera
pero si hay por ejemplo un incendio o
una guerra esto también hace que suba el
pib
por otro lado tenemos la crisis
climática
una situación de emergencia que ya todo
el mundo acepta salvo alguna extraña
forma de vida
consiste básicamente en la acumulación
de gases de efecto invernadero en la
atmósfera la mayor parte de ellos
provenientes de nuestra actividad
económica
ya desde los años 80
se considera un hecho incuestionable que
el planeta no puede soportar este patrón
de emisiones
la correlación entre variables como veis
resulta evidente
en el planeta en este momento estamos
emitiendo 42 giga toneladas de co2 al
año
y la capacidad de absorción del planeta
es de 5
esta acumulación de gases es la que está
provocando el calentamiento
el objetivo es que este incremento de
temperatura no supere 15 grados y esto
se pretende hacer reduciendo los gases a
la mitad en las próximas tres décadas es
decir pasar de 42 a 20 en el año 2030 a
10 en el año 2040 y a 5 en el año 2050
que es la capacidad de absorción del
planeta de esta manera pasaremos a ser
carbono neutrales en 2050
saltamos una década más hasta los años
90 aquí ya se empieza a hablar del
crecimiento verde como la estrategia
para conseguir este objetivo
el crecimiento verde consiste
básicamente en separar el crecimiento
económico de la generación de emisiones
o el uso de combustibles fósiles que en
definitiva son los causantes de los
gases de efecto invernadero
la pregunta que surge entonces y que
sigue vigente hoy es es esto posible
en el año 2018 el ipcc que es el
organismo de naciones unidas que trata
el cambio climático nos ofrece una hoja
de ruta para llegar a este objetivo
como veis la curva no es un tema menor
honestamente si vemos los datos hasta la
actualidad el panorama es desolador
desde 1980 hasta 2009 el uso de recursos
se incrementó en un 98%
literalmente nos comemos el planeta
necesitamos un planeta y medio para
satisfacer nuestras necesidades
cada año
ante este panorama el ipcc elaboró una
serie de alternativas estratégicas para
conseguir el objetivo todas ellas
utilizando el crecimiento verde
no una ni dos concretamente 116
escenarios distintos tranquilos que no
vamos a entrar en detalle en los 110
escenarios 116 pero una cosa así diré de
los 116 110 se basan en las llamadas
tecnologías de baja emisión que
consisten básicamente en capturar los
gases y almacenarlos para evitar así el
calentamiento
la viabilidad a gran escala de estas
tecnologías no está aprobada y de hecho
han recibido bastantes críticas por
parte de colectivos científicos
los seis escenarios restantes se apoyan
en una revolución tecnológica
y promete reducir de una forma drástica
el uso de recursos
las emisiones algo que de nuevo se
muestra bastante improbable
en conclusión el crecimiento verde
aunque éste está teóricamente probado y
está ocurriendo en algunas partes del
mundo es muy poco probable que nos lleve
al objetivo de 1.5 grados en el tiempo
que tenemos
por tanto el crecimiento verde tal y
como está planteado es una ilusión que
nos aleja de las verdaderas estrategias
para luchar contra el calentamiento
global
si miramos por ejemplo la iniciativa
privada en él tenemos una serie de
alternativas por ejemplo hace sólo un
mes salieron estos anuncios de un mayor
fondo de inversión del mundo blackrock
que anuncia que solo
que va a dejar de invertir en
tecnologías en empresas que inviertan en
el uso de combustibles fósiles otra
empresa como bnp
en un informe a inversores
afirma que la rentabilidad de las
renovables ya hace imposible
ya hace imposible que la industria del
petróleo sea competitiva y prevé para
extra un declive implacable
e irreversible
existen ya países que están atreviéndose
a ser valientes gobiernos que asumen la
descarbonización como un reto urgente e
imprescindible
que son capaces de generar tejido
empresarial que son capaces de generar
empleo en definitiva que ven
descarbonización como una oportunidad de
desarrollo
esto que parece una labor titánica ya
está ocurriendo en algunos países estoy
hablando de escocia de islandia de nueva
zelanda países de nuestro entorno por
cierto los tres liderados por mujeres
estos países han creado una alianza esta
alianza tiene como objetivo
repensar el sistema económico y
cuestionar los indicadores de medida por
ejemplo el pib
si nos atrevemos a cuestionar si nos
atrevemos con otros enfoques a mirar la
economía con otros enfoques entonces
surgen preguntas fundamentales en qué
tipo de sociedad queremos vivir qué es
lo realmente importante en la vida
ya lo dijo kennedy en los años 60 el pib
lo mide todo excepto por lo que vale la
pena vivir
cambiamos pues el indicador para que
mida lo que queremos que mida
este viaje nos trae hasta aquí 2020
universidad politécnica de valència
estaréis de acuerdo conmigo en que no
queda otra que aceptar que hay un límite
un techo ecológico que no podemos
rebasar
llevamos 100 años pensando en el crece
en el crecimiento económico como única
forma de vida ahora toca pensar en algo
que normalmente no hacemos donde vivimos
y donde situamos nuestros límites
quizá no haya que separar crecimiento
económico de emisiones que es lo que
llevamos intentando hacer desde hace 20
años
quizá el foco debía estar entre separar
crecimiento económico de bienestar
si nos libramos de la limitante del
crecimiento económico entonces surgen
muchísimas oportunidades imaginar por
ejemplo una década en la que los países
del g20 centran sus esfuerzos en la
descarbonización y no en el crecimiento
del pib arrastrar y amos a todo el resto
de países sería una nueva revolución
humana
un pacto global que transformaría a
nuestras sociedades
nos haría más justos y más humanos y
seguramente hasta más felices muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]